Now we're going to do
something really cool.
I'm going to show you how to build
a parameterized model from data.
What do I mean by parameterized model?
This is an example of a parameterized
model that you're probably familiar with
from algebra.
It's a function of x and
it has these two parameters, m and b.
In fact, as you're probably aware,
this is the equation of a line.
So m and
b are the parameters of that line.
Now for convenience in our
code instead of using m and
b, I'm going to use C0 and
C1, just to be consistent.
Let me motivate this with an example.
Let's suppose we have some
data from an experiment.
Now this can work for
many sorts of experiments, but for now,
let's assume we've taken some
measurements of humidity, and we've
observed on those particular days we
measured the humidity how much it rains.
So each dot here represents one day and
one sample of data.
So on this date, it was this humid,
and it rained that much.
Now we probably have lots more data,
one for each day.
When we look at this data, we see
there's a kind of relationship here.
And our intuition is maybe that
it could be fitted by a line.
Just sort of by eyeballing it,
looks like the line might look about
like that, and so our parameters here
coefficient 0 is equivalent
to the slope here,
and coefficient 1 is the y intercept.
So our task is to find C sub 0 and
C sub 1 that provide the equation for
this line that best fits the data.
The question here is,
how do we reframe this problem so
that it makes sense for our minimizer?
What is it we're trying to minimize?
So restating the problem, suppose we
have our original data points here, and
we're trying to discover the equation
of a line that best fits those points.
Suppose this blue line is a candidate
line and we want to evaluate it.
Is this good or bad?
So the equation for that line is,
our first coefficient times x
plus the second coefficient.
And what the minimizer is going to
do is it's going to vary this C0 and
C1 to try and minimize something.
And so
we have to come up with an equation that
gets lower in value as this
line better fits the data.
What should we use for that equation?
So here's one step towards
solving this problem.
We can take a look at each one
of our original data points and
observe how far away it is from
this line that we're evaluating.
Let's call each of these distances e.
So e sub 0 is that one,
e sub 1 is that one.
Can we come up with
an equation in terms of e or
error that gets us to this solution?